so do you guys actually get together
quite a bit i mean red and green has
been going and going and going in
different forms
uh for so for a long time
90s are you guys still getting together
obviously not over
zoom calls like this but um in person
or on stage or anything like that i mean
i
i'd have to say no guys hey
well no well everybody except you steve
sorry that's just one of those things
i'm sorry you should have gotten the
invite we we get together every weekend
it's actually in hamilton but anyways
doesn't matter we pop just before the
s's
right before the ask we kind of cut out
but uh
steph and peter a lot and bob and i live
very close to each other
even though we don't see each other we
do live close to each other we could
walk there
he did a live show for a while and uh
whenever he was in town we
i think we all pretty much gathered
whenever we could yeah to see the show
how cool was it to be able to go and see
uh see steve
live i love the idea again that red
green was continuing on because
it's become this iconic thing um i never
got a chance to see the live show but
i thought it would have been so fun to
to be there in person for the rest of
you guys what was it like to see
uh red queen uh in a live scenario well
seeing steve
live is very different for us because
it's almost like an outer body
experience you think you're backstage
gonna run on a few seconds
waiting for your cue yeah yeah it felt
very strange but it was wonderful to be
a part of the audience to
to feel the laughter they feel and the
role of the laughter of a room
it was it was really neat jeff did like
zero pressure
there's a great line uh if women don't
find you handsome they should at least
find you handy
who wrote that line how did that land
come to be
and that came out very early days and uh
rick green and i were the only writers
so one of us
came up with that and honestly i don't
know who but he's not here so i did
steve do people see you as like were
they able to see past red green and see
steve smith or were you always red green
to people
just walking down the street like after
handyman corn and all that you have
people to come up to you and ask
you you know how do you fix this how do
you fix that
do you think people want to do stuff the
way uh
you know it's a it's a real mix like in
canada you know i was kind of known
from my wife and i doing smith and smith
so they had that backstory but
so i don't i mean they know i'm not red
green i mean i'm ray green but i'm also
steve smith
in america they a lot of them are
shocked when i i talk and i don't talk
in
in that red green uh harassment raspy
voice so
they they thought it was legit i mean in
parts of minnesota it's drama
but uh
[Music]
i just i like to publicly thank these
guys for building up this
huge wave of demands and i've been able
to get on my little surfboard and
and ride for about 10 years
well i mean like everything from uh
the way that you talk to the way that
you would you know you said that
red green is someone that everybody
knows like someone that people like
they've got that person in their life um
i every time i buy the duct tape i got
it right here
every time i pick up duct tape i think
of red queen did you guys ever think
when you were shooting that show back in
the day
how iconic this thing would become no
in fact i was thinking about it last
night i think steve and i have been
working for about
it was about 35 years steve i think wow
34 35 years ago we did a show called the
comedy mill
and steve and i played two very goofy
akalas
boy scout aquilas and there was an akala
gourd
that was just very officious very lonely
guy and he became
ranger gourd in the red green show um
but i mean right at the very beginning i
i i i know steve one of his
sayings was i give me enough money to do
a show but not enough to care about what
i'm doing
so that was one of the biggest beauties
for an actor is that whatever we got on
set
whenever we you know i was always on
location in a forest tower or something
whenever we did what we did the power
started and stopped there
and and and the decision making so that
was always
really exciting and satisfying as an
actor that you know how about this how
about this and we could try this and
then
um whereas you know bigger bigger
entities
generally speaking there's a chain of
hierarchy that it makes impossible to be
too creative
on that you know on the spur of the
moment
so it's always so much fun always so
many glass
buying duct tape up here in the north
where i live is a little difficult
because
everybody knows the show so you got to
buy two rolls one for you and one to
autograph for the person at the
detective
they just can't believe that you
actually need duct tape in your life
which
i believe they don't need it
i mean you guys were steve you were in
your 40s i think when
when it sort of took off right when the
tv series took off
what did it feel like uh having
something
moving from your mid 40s into 50s up to
now
that was you know you didn't find it
when you were 20.
you found that when you were a little
bit later and it became this huge
success what did it feel like
to be at that stage and see something
just kind of take off
you know i i don't have any regrets at
all i mean i i guess some people i i was
45 when i started doing the show
and that's pretty late to be starting
for i consider myself the colonel
standards of comedy
uh but i i i didn't have to sustain it
for long i didn't think so anyway we did
15 years i mean i
one of the reasons that we stopped doing
the show was like i was turning 60 i was
getting a little
old and now here i am i'm almost 75
thinking that i
i still have something to say but you're
running out of
11 sacred herbs and spices
yeah but i'm getting crispier
[Laughter]
yeah i know it's just the whole thing's
been a miracle i think and i say this a
lot
when when the show was cancelled at the
end of its second season
that was one that started because uh the
letters we were getting from
canadians uh that we got whatever you
got to do get this keep this show on the
air and that was
a real wake-up call for me and i i did a
lot of fighting after that to keep on
yeah the you know i can see back there
you've you've put up something that
looks a bit like possum lodge the the
lodge itself was a
was a character in the show i mean you
could look around in every episode and
see a thousand little things in the
background
um was there anything from the set that
you guys
loved that you took home with you a pat
there must have been something
that you kept i had a lot of choices of
what to take but i ended up taking a
duck decoy because that's something at
least i could keep around the house
without it being too you know
demonstrative like i had that big
switcher that i would wear as harold and
then people said oh did you want to take
that he's like i do but where's it going
to go when that's
going to go up again that i needed
[Laughter]
you wouldn't believe what jeff took home
as a souvenir
well uh i was i was given i was given
the bell from the word game and oh
and the little bell from the word game
sits on my bar
and when every time when peter comes
over well it's a problem because it just
does not stop ringing
[Laughter]
you guys were just talking about the uh
the opportunity you had when you're
creating to not be held down by
i guess human expectations budget
expectations that sort of thing
and in many ways now creators are doing
that with
their youtube channels or on tick tock
or on social media
or things like this are things like this
how do you think that the red green show
you know would have incorporated social
media
if it was still happening on tv or
online
today i i think the show probably would
only be on
social media today i i can't imagine
going in and pitching this show
today in today's environment on it but
on the other hand
we have access to an audience through
that through that
youtubes of the world and so on so i
think
we i guess it would be hard to find the
money to do it but uh
one of the reasons we're now switching
over to a podcast is exactly that i
when i started touring the thing i liked
the most about it was there was no
middleman there was no programmer no
gatekeeper no advertiser
it was just me and an audience and if
they buy tickets then we can keep doing
it
you know so that i think the podcast
puts us in the same category
yeah and you're you know the audience is
going to be there for the podcast you
guys must be excited
uh to be able to bring these characters
back in a different form
um how often are you guys going to be
able to record together is it going to
be
a full cast like what can we expect from
the show
well uh it's similar to the tv show in
format
uh so we'll like these guys will come in
and record a whole bunch of bits and
then i'll sprinkle them throughout the
we're doing 12 episodes maybe one a
month and we'll sprinkle them
them through i'm actually even doing
handyman stuff so
be making things and uh but you won't
see it you won't see anything
so i'm firm believer in the theater of
the mind and
i think it develops not only kids
imaginations but it
even stimulates an old guy's imagination
that sometimes the pictures you can make
in your mind
are better than anything anybody can
kill you
i remember when we started this show
steve that you mentioned this would make
a great radio
show yeah i've i've always loved radio
i'm old enough that
i used to lie in my bed listening to you
know our miss
brooks and jack benny's show on the
radio and and i could picture
i could picture all those people in all
those scenes so i want the
people today to have that shot who never
had the opportunity i did
well i guess a lot of us have enough
experience doing animation where we all
sort of take on characters and there's a
little bit of a different
technique you have to ramp it up just a
touch to to make it a little bit more
um viable as a as a radio thing or as a
just an audio thing
yeah i don't know about you guys
the audience has still been able to to
keep in touch with rugby and though you
have
70 something million views on youtube
for the red green show
yeah for three over 300 episodes
i mean when you started and i want to
know this from each of you individually
because you said after the second season
you got you know canceled
when you first started how long did you
think this
show was going to go for
i didn't think it had much chance once
they brought me on
i agree i agree with that yeah we didn't
have a shot
came on we thought oh it's over now here
we go
after that we knew we were invincible i
remember the first day
when uh steve and i were shooting alone
in the studios back at ch and we were
hardwired into the chairs and we
couldn't move
and you know we'd laugh that we just but
what we're doing is we're discovering
what the comedy was going to be and how
we were going to play together in those
early days
and so i had no idea how long this was
going to go and the second season was so
different than the first
it was in a whole new direction it was
another question of every year just kept
evolving into this new question of
will this be the one that gets us
canceled
and he's he's not exactly telling the
truth i i would have a wireless mic we
could afford one he
he you could run away
they had me leashed to the chair
there's a lot of talk about i think the
very first episodes i did
were in a a very very rickety
kid's treehouse somewhere that was in
the backyard of a friend in hamilton
and i remember that when steve and i got
up there it was
it was it was it was cagey enough but
when the cameraman went up
and then finally sandy richardson who
did a lot of the props
the thing was swaying and i'm surprised
it didn't end there actually
well first as soon as we got more budget
the first thing we did was get him a
better tower
bob how about you how long did you think
this thing was going to go
i had no idea i started in the third
year
so um i was just happy to work
so it was nice when it you know every
season came by
and there was another uh another version
i
i still miss when we would we would go
on location
later on uh and we would always go to
these lovely conservation areas
uh just north of hamilton and june comes
i still miss those days of uh
because we did nothing we just sit
around and eat i mean that was a great
party
and hugely popular on pbs there was a
bunch of us that did you know pbs
pledge breaks down in the states and it
was massive absolutely massive and i
think to steve's credit he
physically drove videotapes around from
affiliate to affiliate and it just
caught on like wildfire
and um yeah i mean it it certainly had
legs it was one of those things where
people thought yeah no we
we this is this is good we want more of
this
the fan mail was huge the the reception
was always tremendous
and genuinely funny like i said like we
all we all had chance to
you know it started funny but then it
just got so much fun because of the
chemistry and everybody involved on set
and you know the the audience that we
had at cbc there was
never a need for any prompting that was
such an electric feel coming out
you were always peter you were always
particularly nervous about
doing stuff in front of the audience
right i'm not i'm not big on an audience
i started in theater but i
i don't want to end in theater yeah yeah
but it was
it was so the energy that we got off of
that uh
crowd at cbc was just electric it was
crazy
yeah so in between we get sometimes uh
comments from
from uh viewers saying you know you turn
down the fake
laughter you know it's too it's too much
it wasn't fake we
i've been on sets where they will have
you know they'll record a take
and then the director will laugh and the
ad will laugh
and that's where the laugh track is
is going to go but to be able to perform
in front of a live audience like that
and peter you said that it was something
that maybe it wasn't your favorite thing
or maybe you were it was nerve-racking
for you
but how much did that drive the energy
of the show
well i suppose after a while it did i
mean i've done a lot of sitcoms in front
of live audiences and it was
a thing you know it became a thing it
was sort of the steam that drove the
engine forward a bit but
but for me as an actor i'm i'm i'm too
much of a perfectionist i
i like really focusing in on what i'm
doing
and so if there's a reaction that might
just sort of draw my
my attention away or the laugh came not
where i expected it
or something else where it was just a
fact that i was performing for
however many people in the audience as
opposed to how many more thousands more
that were actually behind that
you know watching on tv that was my only
hesitation
but you know it's a muscle like anything
else and god knows
everyone else on these screens here are
used to more use of that than i am
it was interesting in the first two
years because we didn't have a live
audience
and then the third year we went to
london and there was a live audience
remember steve ran backstage when
we're never going back because the
audience told us when the laughs were
you know
and which was great and because the
writing was so tight
you didn't really have to improve on
things very often but it made our
performances really sharp because you
could ride those laps and stretch them
out and
and it was really honest versus the
first two years we just had to assume
where the laughter was and
play it but from that point on that
third season that audience was
another character in the room see i'm
okay with that because the first few
seasons i was always up in a treehouse
and it was just
even the camera person i love that
i really miss that
there's a joke that when the last
episode aired you guys said
that people would be like oh finally
when the last episode aired but when
that last episode actually did air what
was response what did people say to you
it was really it was really a mix and it
continues to be to this day
i mean they're really grateful that the
show and we did gosh 15 years for crying
out loud
and a movie and a movie uh so there was
like
it was a mixture of gratitude and they
they wish that it
you know it would keep going they keep
asking me if i'm going to do
something you know we're going to do
more episodes and i said well no it was
time to move forward and then i
went and did the tour wrote a couple of
books and now i'm ready to move forward
with the podcast
it's hard as you get older to come up
with new things that aren't
medical procedures so i'm delighted that
we had a podcast to go
you